dominicano di 30 anni è figlia di un la
narcotrafficante ed è ancora vergine
perché ancora vergine perché il padre è
molto
protettivo e non vuole assolutamente che
nessuno le si avvicini quindi lei ogni
volta che porta a casa un fidanzato
fidanzato puntualmente viene da dire
allontanato ho fatto fuori sono state
coinvolte in questo progetto tramite la
cartella del film criminalità nottata
per alcuni video però i miei video
magari chi mi segue la conosce mi ha
proposto questa parte che mi sono subito
trovato cucita addosso perché comunque
io sono meta spagnola quindi facilita
con lo spagnolo
[Musica]
nuovo per essere un vero idolo delle
donne deve avere solo tutta la simpatia
deve farci ridere farci morire dalle
risate deve conquistarsi la simpatia
perché la bellezza pasta la simpatia